foreign
stressful situation to be in as well
right you go to the RMR you fail to
qualify now it's showdown time another
chance to get into a stadium a proper
land and you fall at the first hurdle
you know it is a bleak black hole for
Evil Geniuses the fact that you 've got
my rating don't you think that I'm aware
I suck you're paying them a lot of money
they're not playing well they're partner
team they're exposed to playing against
the best teams in the world and then
they can't win in their region what do
we do we know what do we do what do they
do
hey folks before we get into the video I
want to let you know that we have new
merch like this awesome touch grass
hoodie I'm wearing right now we have
lots of cool designs so please head over
to the score Esports merch store and
pick up something nice for yourself okay
so in January 2022 North American
Counter-Strike was looking for a win it
had been four long years since Cloud9
made history in Boston and the North
American scene had totally deteriorated
since na just died in in CS hard the
Region's best roster Team Liquid spent
the online era in Europe because playing
in North America just wasn't worth it
and many former Pros called it quits
either to stream or to play valorant
still there were some holdouts who were
determined to take nacs back to the top
despite 2021's challenges and a
multi-year drought at Premier Events EG
stepped up to the task of revitalizing
nacs and they already had a few crucial
pieces in place Bulgarian Opera Circ was
a rising star in n a and no one defusing
the bomb yet he's
and Breezy was a promising rifler who
had an explosive start to his time with
eg in 2019. does Breezy actually get a
plant oh no the kriegs are coming the
Craigs are coming oh wait maybe more
no way oh my goodness
[Applause]
keeping both of these players for the
new roster made obvious sense but the
big question was who could EG bring in
to make them shine they acquired one of
the French scenes most experienced
coaches Damien Malik Marcel who once
headed up G2 and team envy and the team
signed automatic rush and Stewie 2K
three players were a part of the Cloud9
roster that gave n a its only major on
paper it looked like one of the better
rosters that could be assembled from
what was available in North America in
reality though there were plenty of
question marks about the team's
performance as was discussed on hltv
confirmed three of the five players have
been underperforming consistently in the
last year
oh well I guess Rush had some time off
but yeah he can get included into that
and then automatic hasn't been playing
the game for a significant period of
Time evil
evil new roster started their time
together at a 30-day boot camp with
Stewie as the team's new igl but in a
shocking later interview with One PV
after leaving the team EG's assistant
coach Evie revealed that even on day one
things were off to a rough
starts
it is
[Music]
everyone on to say that it wasn't as if
he and Mala gave up but the potential
issues within the roster were clear from
the get-go and once EG debuted in the
blast Premiere spring group stage the
internal problems spilled over into
their gameplay Apex swings for it as the
jumping on the other side and that AK
will bring down both the SMGs suits up
with a single kill on Breeze probably
enough here to free catching as he comes
out they just have all the map control
absolutely Stellar performance from
Vitality to start this with the season
SB gun then they take down EG to open
the whole thing with they don't know the
late rotators are coming in there push
there's no flank Cirque misses his shot
it all falls on Stewie a leash clears
the corner and Team Liquid clear EG and
with 35 seconds on this clock it feels
like more of an inevitability that big
have done it yet again in the face of
adversity off of the back of a map one
loss they run this series 2-1 take
vertigo and send EG soaring EG's first
outing didn't Inspire confidence that
this new roster could end up as a top
team sure maybe fans expected a lopsided
loss to vitality and maybe that
close-thought series with liquid was
proof that the team had potential but
losing to big was kind of embarrassing
with blast as their disappointing debut
Evil Geniuses had just under two months
to be ready for the Antwerp major if
they could even qualify an NA Open
qualifier had to be easy prey for the
caliber of players on EG but it didn't
go that way Stewie's team lost a close
Best of one to Strife Esports if there
were warning Bells before this loss
triggered a full-on emergency alarm Days
Later EG qualified for the RMR but only
after a second place finish to party
astronauts and then with six possible
slots available EG had to play a
tiebreaker against 9z to stay alive at
the RMR it was close but the out come
with still a disaster Breeze goes into
the site commits to the plan cgt's
moving forward
EG weren't going to compete against the
best in the world at Antwerp because EG
couldn't even beat the best in North
America
not winning a single Series in EPL
season 15 and not qualifying for the
main event of the year put a huge
question mark next to their roster
you're paying them a shitload of money
they're not playing well their partner
team they're exposed to playing against
the best teams in the world and then
they can't win in their region what do
we do we know what do we do what do they
do it's bad for YouTube that they didn't
qualify but I wasn't particularly
surprised I probably if you ask me I
probably would have favorite zero zero
Nation to make it over over Egypt Evil
Geniuses gave their new roster a month
of Runway before they even had to play
in a tournament they shelled out for
huge names they expected big things but
halfway through April less than three
months after finalizing the roster it
was already looking like this experiment
was destined to fail and that's the
problem Fiji on a good day they could
beat I wouldn't say anyone but those
teams on a bad day they can probably
lose to anyone the worst part was that
since they didn't qualify for the major
there wasn't much for EG to look forward
to even the events the team did attend
in late spring and early summer didn't
exactly Inspire confidence what a
stressful situation to be in as well
right you go to the RMR you fail to
qualify for the Antwerp major you come
back home you play the Dallas qualifier
you get eliminated you're not playing in
your own country now it's showdown time
another chance to get into a stadium a
proper land and you fall at the first
hurdle you know it is a bleak black hole
for Evil Geniuses desperate times called
for desperate measures and EG were
desperate in mid-may they cut ties with
assistant coach Evie and analyst HEPA
and benched coach Malek and then EG did
something crazy calling it The Blueprint
EG signed 10 more players picking up two
upstart n a rosters Carpe Diem and party
astronauts this move raised a ton of
questions but the real bombshell was
what former assistant coach Evie told
French site 1pv about what was happening
behind the scenes TV uh
unsurprisingly Stewie had a lot to say
in an intense stream the next day like I
understand my attitude is not the best
I'm a guy who does not like to lose I
will win in any other condition I would
do anything to win and anyone who's been
watching me anyone who's playing on my
team knows that like they know that
Winning is Everything To Me the fact
that you even brought up my rating
don't you think that I'm aware I suck
that I'm putting
the team in front of me that I'm worried
about the other side of the map Stewie
said it himself he didn't like to lose
but that was what egcs roster seemed to
do Best by summer 2022 even with the
so-called blueprint in place but
out of all the laws to do everything he
can to keep EG alive and it's just not
gonna happen it was a good effort right
here for able Geniuses I thought we saw
some glimpses Jay over the course of
this entire map but astralis was the
outclassing element and uh my goodness
flame F was just an absolute tank pone
alone just trying to make anything
happen but it's not gonna be and there's
the win coming through from a strollers
not really tested a massive amount and
so Stewie decided his time on the roster
was over in July he became EG's newest
content creator and began to stream
valorent and we back baby we back
a disastrous six months on EG CS go team
ended with Stewie taking a step back
from competing and his pro career looks
like it's over at least for now but that
hasn't stopped EG from carrying on with
the blueprint there are still a ton of
players on their roster and hell maybe
we'll see the model actually pay off one
day what we do know is that the Stewie
LED roster that lasted half a year is
unfortunately one of the biggest flops
in nacs history considering the amount
of money likely spent versus the results
it could actually be the worst Stewie
has said that he has things to work on
that he can get better and return to his
former glory if he decided to stay away
from CS forever that would probably be
the most surprising thing about this
whole mess for now though all the Cs
Community can see is the wreckage of one
of the biggest disasters in CS go
history and the players that got dragged
down with it
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock